-Thank you very much
for watching us, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
I want to say hello and welcome
back to Kamal Gray,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great to see you, Kamal.
Roots, did you miss --
Did you miss Kamal?
-No, no, not really.
-Yeah, yeah.
We'll dub it in later.
We'll put it in post.
Welcome to the show again,
everybody.
Do you guys know this?
This is crazy.
The Olympics were supposed to
start around this time.
Isn't that bizarre?
Yeah, but now with the virus,
it's just President Trump on TV.
So instead of watching
gymnastics and swimming,
we're watching
a guy bend over backwards
to stay above water.
Last night,
Trump held a 27-minute briefing
and basically
read the entire thing.
Fun fact -- on his script,
all the words were in
a little bubble coming from
a cartoon elephant.
Trump kept it short
and stuck to the script.
Unfortunately, he sounded like
a kid reading a book report
he got off of SparkNotes.
[ As Trump ] "Gatsby" was great.
Some even say the greatest.
[ Normal voice ] But Trump
kicked things off with
something I didn't
expect to hear
five months into the pandemic.
-We are in the process of
developing a strategy
that's going to be
very, very powerful.
-Trump said working on a
strategy isn't that hard.
He found one on his desk
from the CDC
marked "February 1st."
He's working on a strategy now?
That's like Ford's Theatre being
like, "Good news, everyone.
We're beefing up security."
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
he's working on a strategy now.
He was like, "The key
to disaster response is...
timing."
Yeah, Trump said
he's in the process
of developing a strategy.
He sounds like every dad
that's asked,
"When are you going to build
me that tree house?"
"I'm working on a strategy.
Just let me get another beer.
We'll talk about it tomorrow."
Meanwhile, after months of
sounding upbeat about the virus,
Trump seemed like
he was changing his tune.
-It will probably,
unfortunately,
get worse before it gets better.
-Where have I heard that before?
Oh, yeah.
Dr. Fauci has said
it every day since March.
That's reassuring, though.
We've from
"make America great again"
to "It will get worse
before it gets better."
Asked when it will get worse,
Trump was like,
"Oh, when I force
all the schools to reopen."
Well, to prove how seriously
he's taking things,
the president decided to talk
about his own commitment
to wearing a mask.
-If you can, use the mask.
When you can, use the mask.
If you're close to each other,
if you're in a group,
I would put it on
when I'm in a group.
I have no problem
with the masks.
-Yeah, Trump said
he's always supported masks.
He was like, "I wore one
far back as 11 days ago.
Oh, there was also
Halloween 1968.
I was Bozo the Clown."
Once Trump finished
reading from his script,
he went off book,
which is always a mistake,
and took some questions.
One reporter asked
for his thoughts on
Jeffrey Epstein's longtime
associate, Ghislaine Maxwell,
being imprisoned on
sex-trafficking charges.
Let's hear how that went.
-I just wish her well, frankly.
I've met her numerous times
over the years,
especially since I lived
in Palm Beach
and I guess they lived
in Palm Beach.
But I wish her well.
-Ugh...
-What?
I would do a spit take right now
if it wasn't so dangerous.
[ Laughter ]
Later on, Trump had everyone
sign a Hallmark sympathy card
that said...
They're always sold out
when I go to the store.
Right after he wished her well,
Trump's staff was like,
"Oh, yeah.
This is why we stopped
doing these."
Moving on to sports,
over in Poland,
some motorcycle-racing fans came
up with a creative way
to watch their home team.
Take a look at this.
Yeah, they rented 21 cranes
so they could watch their
local team race.
Although, when you're watching
from a crane,
it's kind of hard to leave
without the racers noticing.
"I'm going to take off, guys."
[ Whirring ]
They tried to do the wave,
but it was
absolutely terrifying.
"Aah! Okay."
And, finally, some quirky, fun
news that we could all use.
A man in Jamaica
won the lottery,
but look at how he decided
to collect his prize.
-A lottery winner in
Jamaica showed up in
a Darth Vader costume
to claim his check for
95 million Jamaican dollars.
That's about
650,000 American dollars.
-Ever since
he won all that money,
a dozen people
have come up to him like,
"You are my father? Please?"
Meanwhile, his ex
was watching that like,
"Yeah, still no regrets."
You guys know I've been
trying to keep up with
the news at much as I can,
but when it comes to
news about the economy,
there's only one place
I'd turn to get the facts.
It's "Market Crunch."
♪♪
Welcome back to CNBC's
"Market Crunch."
I'm Hal Grud.
This week's market
in a nutshell --
America wants to order a
Happy Meal with a toy in it
but just keeps getting a
Grumpy Meal
with a piece of black licorice
stuck to the bag.
Let's break it down. Break it!
In commodities,
we're seeing widespread reports
of couples getting married --
for the rice.
Here comes the "no, thank you"!
Crude oil continues to
plunge this week,
forcing people
to sell their cars --
for gas money!
Not pumped!
Let's look at gold.
Today, 2 Chainz is now just
1 Chain -- singular.
That's not enough chains.
In international trade,
a fake Nigerian prince
I met online tried to
wire money to me.
Reverse scam.
Let's look at the closing bell.
What?! No bell?
They had to sell it?
Clang, clang, gone!
And now, time for
my "Market Perspective."
♪♪
This is usually
the part of the show
where I offer my expert opinion
on the market,
but these days, I can't even
put in my two cents.
No cents!
Up next, the pot.
Will we have one to piss in?
No piss pot?!
Also, the Dow.
More like Down.
This has been "Market Crunch."
♪♪
-"Market Crunch."